new research raises more concerns about
a troubling side effect of the pandemic
the effect it's having on advanced
breast cancer cases here in the u.s data
from one cancer clinic in california
shows that the number of new advanced
stage four
breast cancer cases jumped from 1.9
percent of all cases in 2019
to 6.2 percent in 2020. the biden
administration says there have been more
than nine and a half million
missed cancer screenings in the u.s
because of the pandemic cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus joins us now
dr aegis good morning that is a big
number of missed screenings how
dangerous is
it well you know
1.7 million people a year are diagnosed
with cancer in the united states and we
took a pause on screening yet disease
didn't pause and so what we're seeing is
patients presenting with advanced
disease advanced disease means that it's
no longer curable and obviously for each
one of those lives you feel sorry that
we literally we dropped the ball there
because our hospitals were full and we
couldn't do cancer screening
so are preventative screenings
down in other types of cancer or is
breast cancer a particular category
it's all of them obviously breast cancer
mammography getting a mammogram we know
will save the life of a woman because it
diagnoses cancer early colonoscopy
cervical cancer prostate cancer skin
cancer
all of those we took a pause on and yet
the disease themselves didn't take a
pause and the earlier you catch these
the much much more likely they're
curable and we miss that window
unfortunately in many people
yeah and as we've seen dr agus you know
cancer does not discriminate how often
should women get them when i was coming
up we were told you should get it once a
year and you should start at the age of
40. is that still true
yeah it really depends on who you listen
to and so the clear data from u.s
preventive task force that starting at
age 50 you can get one every two years
starting age 40 is really in the hands
of the woman based on her family history
and her ability to really tolerate risk
i'm recommending everybody get one at
age 40. i really think it it works and
it saves lives if you have dense breasts
you need it may need an mri or a
different kind of screening because the
mammogram won't work in that setting but
it's critically important that we screen
women today for breast cancer catch it
early where it clearly is curable we're
going to save a lot of lives
dr aegis as we move into a different
phase of the pandemic are preventative
screening rates uh getting back to
pre-pandemic levels for example i
haven't been in two years to get uh a
dermatology test to make sure these
freckles stay adorable so i'm doing that
next month but i'm wondering if people
are getting back to that level again
vlad you cannot stop i mean there's a
lot of preventative maintenance there
wasn't going to the united states
i know but but literally i mean doctor's
offices are remarkable at blocking the
virus and about making it safe for
people to be there and when you can
imagine if we deferred millions of
screenings everyone is in line now and
i'm seeing that in my patients right
they want to get a scanner they want to
get a screening and there's a month
delay or there's a two month delay it
was before they could get it in a few
days everyone be patient sign up and get
those screenings that were missed we
have to get back on track we have to
focus on health in our country and on
prevention more than every anything and
we're ready for it right we are now safe
to go out and get those screenings go to
your doctor get your blood drawn that
weren't drawn before get that skin exam
get that gyn exam that mammogram or that
prostate test or colonoscopy get them
yeah good advice although vlad i have
your chart here actually and uh your
your freckles are according to your
doctor adored
they did a little as long as they say
that way i'll find out in a month
thank you dr hages as always we
appreciate it my friend